RICHARD HYNDMAN: Ping ping.
Hey there.
Welcome to this week's Android
Developer Office Hours from
Google London.
I'm Richard Hyndman.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Stephan
Linzner.
NICK BUTCHER: Nick Butcher.
CHRIS BANES: Chris Banes.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We're all
here to answer Android
development questions and
generally talk about Android
development topics this week.
Welcome to the people who have
joined us in the Hangout.
We've got Johan and Yossi
and Giuseppe there.
Hey, guys.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: And there's
blue, Ali, on the end.
Hi, Ali.
ALI: Hello.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: There's a
salesman of course, Paul
Hanson as well, and our
video is very good.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey.
I don't know what
is the problem.
NICK BUTCHER: But at least
he's factory [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: What are
you drinking there?
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Do
you think he is?
[INAUDIBLE]
color.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN:
I know, right?
I haven't learned
my [INAUDIBLE]
colors properly yet.
So we're going to start this
week's show off with a little
announcement.
This is going to be the last
of the Android Developer
Office Hours.
We're taking a break for
Google I/O, which
is now 28 days away.
27 days?
It's coming very, very quickly,
very quickly for
anyone's who's got to write
a presentation, get it
rehearsed, perfect it up, and
then live in the next 30 days.
So we're taking some time to
focus on Google I/O now.
We'll be all heading out to
Mountian View soon for
rehearsals and all that
sort of good stuff.
So it's going to be hard to keep
the show running through
that period.
We will be back after I/O when
we should have a brand new
studio here in London, so
everything will be a bit more
professional.
We won't have to turn the lights
down to this grainy
level to make it not
look super bright.
NICK BUTCHER: And hopefully
Chris won't be able to pull
the power out just before
[INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: I'm sure I'll still
find a way to do it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We're going to
actually use tape to tape
all the plugs in
our new studio.
So we're going to come back with
a new show after Google
I/O. So these last 25 minutes
of Android Developer Office
Hours for this month, I
guess, [INAUDIBLE].
So we'll kick off, see
if anyone in the
Hangout has a question.
Can we jump into
the Moderator?
MALE SPEAKER: We've got
lots of of moderators.
JOHAN PELGRIM: I've
got a question.
I want to create a widget,
but I only have a server.
I can only do pull to the
server for information.
And of course, with the widget,
you have to keep the
refresh to a minimum.
I don't know what it was,
like 30 minutes or an
hour with the device.
Is there still a way, maybe with
a service, to frequently
pull the back end service and
notify a widget to update, or
do you have any experience with
that kind of scenario?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah,
so can't you--
are you going to know when the
data's ready on the server?
Can you look at the GCM
which points to a
service on the device?
JOHAN PELGRIM: It's updating
frequently.
Basically, it's a music player,
so to speak, but we
don't have a two-way
communication.
It's only one-way, so the--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: But you could
use GCM to go from your server
to our servers, and
we'll notify the
device to do an update.
JOHAN PELGRIM: No, no, no.
It's a proprietary server, so
it's running some Linux or
PERL or whatever.
So I don't have any influence
on that set of parts.
I can pull the server for
information, but there's no
way the server is going to
communicate back to me when a
next song is playing
or whatever.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so you
could [INAUDIBLE] on the
device, but it sounds like your
best bet is going to set
up some kind of another server
side thing, so like an App
Engine project or something
like that to pull it.
And when something has changed,
then poke our GCM
servers, and we'll deliver a
message to the device to tell
it to then update the widget.
JOHAN PELGRIM: That is the way
to go, otherwise you're going
to have the servers running,
pulling too often and draining
the battery.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, if pulling's
your only option,
then try and do it off device,
because it's going to destroy
the battery.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: And check
Richard's talk from last
year's I/O. He has some good
tips on that, because if
you're pulling every five
minutes, it's going to keep
the radio on maximum power and
crazy things like that.
So there were some good tips
about battery usage and
[INAUDIBLE] if you
have to do it.
JOHAN PELGRIM: OK, great.
Thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE].
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: I have
a question, guys.
RICHARD HYNDMAN:
Hey, Giuseppe.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Hey.
We use a [INAUDIBLE]
Google Drive API version
one in our application.
Two days ago, we found an update
using the Google API
plug-in for Eclipse, and
then this upgraded to
version two, OK?
Starting the update through
the Google Play Store, and
about 3% of our worldwide users,
they are experiencing
invalid file corrupted.
The only change that we have
done, just update this API and
then republish the APK, and now
they are getting end time
from the Google Play Store, they
are getting invalid file.
Do you have any suggestions?
Anything that I can check?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I've seen this
happen once or twice,
very rarely before.
And the Google Play Store is
cached throughout the world at
various cache servers.
And occasionally, it does appear
that a file may get
corrupted on one of
those servers.
And the best way to resolve the
issue is just to republish
the application again
into the Play Store.
I've seen it happen
a couple of times.
I've had people mention it.
And when they republish, all the
caches get cleared again
and flushed and it goes through,
and then it all
starts working again and--
NICK BUTCHER: Just change your
version number and spit out a
new signed APK.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It's the
quickest and easiest way to
get around the problem.
If that fixes it,
then fantastic.
I guess it will.
It may also be in some
operator's cache somewhere.
It may not be in one
of our caches.
These APK files are quite large,
and people cache a lot
of stuff on the [INAUDIBLE]
internet.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Richard, why
this happened just to a
few customers and
not to everyone?
If the file is corrupted on
the Google server, why--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: No, no.
Not on a Google server, it will
be corrupted on a cache
somewhere on the internet.
It could be on one Telco
operator's server in one
country for one group
of people.
It could be anywhere.
Often, you'll see that you get
clusters of people who suffer
from this issue at
one time, though.
And the easiest way
to get around
it is to just republish.
It may not even be in our
content delivery network.
It could be somewhere outside.
I've never debugged it enough
to find out exactly where in
the system these corrupted
files occur.
CHRIS BANES: It could
be anywhere.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: So this
problem is not the first time.
Already, you had some experience
about that.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yes, it's the
third time I've someone now
mention that a group of users
are getting a corrupt file.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: I got it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN:
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Play Store here, and never have
we been able to find the
corrupted file on our system.
So I'm guessing it's outside of
our network, but who knows?
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Thank
you very much.
Thank you very much.
I got it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
Cheers, Giuseppe.
Have you got one lined
up from the
Moderator we can jump into?
CHRIS BANES: Yes.
So Andy from India has asked
[INAUDIBLE], Web View memory
is not garbage collected.
Is there any way to do that?
Thank you.
I'm not exactly sure what
you mean by that.
I don't really know.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Which
bit of it?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
it's [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHAN LINZNER: I remember
there were some issues with
sometimes the Web View keeping
a reference of current
activity and that the garbage
collection was kicking in at a
later time.
I think we had a similar
problem, but I think we tried
to set everything--
we even queried the current
activity and we're setting
everything to now--
but then we didn't have really
a solution for it.
But I know this has happened
to us, too.
CHRIS BANES: One thing I've
found out actually is that
there's a Destroy method on
Web View, which apparently
removes all residencies.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: What
we used to call it.
Of course, the whole
Android now.
STEPHAN LINZNER: But if you use
tracing tools and dump the
memory, you will see that you
still leak the activity
because the leaked activity
is not garbage collected.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, but if you
destroy on the Web View, will
it not release the
activity, right?
STEPHAN LINZNER: I think
it was not happening.
But it's one year ago, so I
don't know if it's a bug in
the framework.
But I'm just saying that I've
experienced something like
this before, where the activity
that was leaked was
not garbage collected.
But we then came up with
a solution for it.
CHRIS BANES: But it sounds
like you're only going to
really have problems with this
if you have multiple Web
Views, so try and condense
it down, I guess.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't think
there's much we can do.
We should move on.
CHRIS BANES: Yep.
So [? Avidewi ?], I hope
I pronounced it.
Apology if I've pronounced
it wrong.
Why was there introduced a 4,000
character limit on text
to speech item in Ice
Cream Sandwich?
The text to speech service.
STEPHAN LINZNER:
Where is this?
CHRIS BANES: Honestly, I don't
really know, but I'm guessing
it's due to memory
constraints.
So if you imagine that you have
4,000 characters, which
is quite a lot, actually--
it's a good paragraph,
two paragraphs--
to be able to convert that text
into speech, it will take
a fair bit of memory,
RAM-wise.
So I'm guessing the thought
behind it was that you have to
split it up yourself and
then do it on demand.
As you finish your speech,
request another 4,000
characters and go on,
go on, go on.
NICK BUTCHER: Wasn't that Ice
Cream Sandwich where the
conversation thing is where we
can just keep on talking and
it keeps up the constant
dictation?
Is that maybe--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
the API [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
keyboard.
CHRIS BANES: So maybe they're
using that [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHAN LINZNER: [INAUDIBLE]
text to a speech.
Maybe it's like you say, it's
just to prevent you from
making errors, because sometimes
you're just passing
in a string, and maybe sometimes
you don't know how
long it is.
MALE SPEAKER: The interesting
thing is that previously, this
splitting was done inside
the speech engine.
I've checked the source code for
all those APIs, and on pre
[INAUDIBLE], the splitting was
done inside the speech
service, regardless
of the size.
But now, it's a bit more
complicated because we'll have
to split the text and base
it after the first one is
completed and so on.
And this actually made the work
with the speech service a
bit complicated than
it was before.
NICK BUTCHER: And have you
looked at the change log on
that file where you found
the splitting?
Is there any comments in the
Commit to explain why the
limit was introduced?
MALE SPEAKER: I did not see
all the Commits, I just
checked the source code.
I think I also posted a
link on the question.
CHRIS BANES: So my guess of
why they changed it from
splitting it in sort of
framework to make you do it
instead is so you can split it
on an end of sentence or end
of paragraph.
So you're not doing text to
speech and then you have a
random word at the end,
so you can do more
contextual sort of--
NICK BUTCHER: That
makes sense.
You know much more about the
content than we do, so you
could probably make a more
intelligent break.
I imagine that's
a [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, OK.
NICK BUTCHER: This is just
our [INAUDIBLE].
But yeah, check out, if you
found the place where the
splitting goes on, if you go to
the Google code repository,
which has all the Commit history
and so on, then you
should be able to see the reason
why the change was
introduced.
It should be in the Commit
history, hopefully.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, thanks.
CHRIS BANES: Thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, thanks
for the question.
And he's gone.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Just because
we've got quite a lot more
viewers now than we did at the
start, I'll restate the thing
I said at the start, that this
is going to be the final
Android Developer
Office Hours.
We are going to stop this now
for once we get through Google
I/O, and then after Google I/O,
we're going to have a new
studio here in London.
We're going to come back
with a new show.
NICK BUTCHER: A vengeance.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: A vengeance
and a new show.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE].
Any more live questions,
or should we crack on?
Ah, there's a--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: There's Viva
NICK BUTCHER: Viva.
Newly tattooed Viva.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Oh
yeah, I saw that.
It's the first of three
tattooing [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Anyway,
questions for Dev.
Chris?
CHRIS BANES: So Giuliano from
Brazil has asked, when will
you release the new update of
Google Maps Android API
Version Two?
Why don't you open
source the API so
we can fix it ourselves?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Well,
that's interesting.
It still needs to be pushed
out to every single device
with the Google Maps API on
it, so fixing it yourself
wouldn't help too much.
And we have a good team working
on it, they're just--
NICK BUTCHER: Well, it's
proprietary code.
So Google Maps isn't an
open source project.
Google Maps is a Google
proprietary project.
So that's the reason it's
not open source.
Feel free, the best way
you can contribute
is by finding bugs.
Like use the Public
Bug Tracker.
We do check all the
bugs there.
As you see, one update's
already been
chipped for the Maps.
And if there are other
bugs, hopefully we'll
get to those as well.
But yeah, file bugs.
So thanks.
Next one?
CHRIS BANES: So Paul from
England has asked, with Web
View, how can I work with it to
know when a page does a get
or post request, and see
the headers and deal
with redirect requests?
I don't think you
actually can.
I looked for the API, the deep
down Web View API, and I
couldn't find a way of actually
getting to requests.
It's all done deep
down into WebKit.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, you just
override the URL loading.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, and that's
as close as you can get, is
override URL, but you
can't get to the
actual physical requests.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: You have to
implement your own browser.
CHRIS BANES: Exactly.
You have to use Apache or URL
Connection and do it yourself,
which is [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: So you
could do that.
You could override the URL
loading, right, and then at
that point, do the web requests
yourself and look at
all the headers and then decide
what you need to do,
and then download the HTML
and just set it on
the Web View, right?
CHRIS BANES: Exactly.
NICK BUTCHER: So you'd have to
insert yourself everywhere in
the process.
CHRIS BANES: And you'd lose
incremental loading
and things like that.
NICK BUTCHER: Right.
CHRIS BANES: You can
still [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Was that you?
Was Paul from England
Paul who's on the--
Paul Hanson?
Or is there another Paul
in England who's
got an Android question.
Maybe he's nodding behind
his avatar.
NICK BUTCHER: Maybe.
He says it was him.
Ah, Yossi's joined as well.
RICHARD HYNDMAN:
Oh hey, Yossi.
Nice [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Right,
next question.
Let's move on.
CHRIS BANES: Right, Carousel.
Dear guys, as you know, Gallery
was deprecated.
View Pager Item has a new
property to display free
items, but could you advise us
on a Carousel component?
I've found many
[? which   were   under ?]
Gallery.
So can you--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Do the
horizontal List View?
That's what we would
recommend.
Whatever happened to that?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, this
is a good question.
We've seen this before.
So essentially, a lot of people
want Gallery-type
behavior, but with
Gallery being
deprecated, don't use it.
And so the advice docs say
either to use a Horizontal
Scroll View or to use
a View Pager.
So Horizontal Scroll View will
just give you the scrolling
behavior, but it's not an
adaptive view, so it's not
going to be very good for
extremely large data sets.
View Pager is great.
I'm not sure what you mean
by the free pages thing.
I think you're talking about
set partial page widths so
that you can set page width so
you can have more than one
item on the screen.
But the problem with that is
that it's always left aligned,
so you're never going to get
that centering type behavior
that you get with Gallery.
So if that's really what you
want, you can either use
Gallery, or you could use
View Pager and do some
modifications to it to try and
get it to center and have the
edges peeking out, whatever
the behavior you
might need to do.
But essentially, you need
to do a bit of work.
CHRIS BANES: Just because
Gallery's deprecated doesn't
mean you can't use it.
And also, I've seen plenty
implementations of Gallery
which add view recycling,
and there's a lot
on GitHub and stuff.
So just have a Google and see.
STEPHAN LINZNER: There are also
some libraries that use
Horizontal Scroll View
to implement a
custom scroll view.
JOHAN PELGRIM: I think the three
refers to the fact that
View Pager holds, while the
current page of course, and
the previous and the next
in cache, so that
might be the three.
I don't know.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: You can set the
page [INAUDIBLE] as well,
yeah, as fragile.
NICK BUTCHER: Next.
CHRIS BANES: Shienza has asked,
I want to refresh a Web
View in Line, and you bracket it
for avenue content without
the white flash.
What are my options?
I'm open to faking it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Take him with
you in the background and
replace the first one?
Waste memory.
We've had the white flash
question quite a bit as well.
There isn't a good
answer to it.
CHRIS BANES: Go Native.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, that
really is the answer.
It sounds flippant, but Web
View is an out of the box
component, and it has
certain limitations.
And if you're butting up against
those, it might be
your only option.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: And if it's
only a small amount of HTML in
there, Text View can
process some HTML.
So you might do a Text
View inside it
instead of a Web View.
Have a lot less overhead to use
the Text View with HTML
formatting instead
of a Web View.
NICK BUTCHER: Voicemail from
HTML, a very expensive call.
But you could cache it.
CHRIS BANES: You could always,
expose JavaScript methods and
call them through Open URL.
So the JavaScripts within
the actual web
page updates the page.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Just
do a lot of testing.
You'll be fine.
CHRIS BANES: So another
library question.
Winkey Wong has asked--
NICK BUTCHER: Ah, she's
in the Hangout.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHRIS BANES: Is there a library
for Android that can
make the sound effect as
page falls for IOS?
I don't know.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: If there's
not, you should write one.
NICK BUTCHER: I know the Google
Books application does
this, and that was all written
using Render Script to make it
all look [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: That Render
Script is open source, not the
Google Books one, but we do
have a page turning Render
Script that's open sourced.
NICK BUTCHER: You do?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It's
the flat line.
It doesn't have the page corner
curling, but it has the
flat line turning.
It's in the Render
Script samples.
NICK BUTCHER: In the
SDK samples?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: The SDK
samples, [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: There we go.
It's on your machine.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It's not quite
as good as the Google
Books version, but it is--
CHRIS BANES: It's a good
starting point.
Maybe you can update it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Of course,
using Render Scripts are well
documented.
You'll be fine.
CHRIS BANES: And deprecated.
Their graphics is.
I have a display.
OK, next question.
We've got some new joiners.
Welcome, everyone
who's joined us.
Any questions from the
live participants?
Just speak up, or you can use
the sidebar and we'll read it
out if you want to type it in
instead, if you don't have a
mic or anything.
NICK BUTCHER: Take
that as a no.
CHRIS BANES: Dead silence.
So 2MI from Hungary
has asked--
I'm going to paraphrase
the question
because it's quite long.
What's the best way of getting
a contact photo
from a contact URI?
He mentions that you can
actually use past URI to Image
View, or is it best to use
open contact photo input
stream, and get the input
stream and [INAUDIBLE]
from there?
And I said that the best way is
actually just using input
stream, because then, from the
input stream, you can have
close control over how the
actual bitmap is decoded.
NICK BUTCHER: Because you might
want to use an in sample
size or something like
that to have a much
faster, smaller bitmap.
CHRIS BANES: Exactly.
So you can use Bitmap Factory
to actually decode the input
stream to how you want.
That's it, really.
I always go input stream with
URIs to have close control.
NICK BUTCHER: And if you want
to look at using those in
sample size and so on, where
can you learn about that?
CHRIS BANES: There's a newish
bitmap training class called
Managing Bitmap Memory, which
documents all this, as well as
some techniques of caching and
that kind of stuff, all that
goodness, and that was
added last month.
Have a look at it.
NICK BUTCHER: So there's no
point opening a massive
contact photo, which they can
be, just to scale it down.
You may as well open it scaled
using the [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: Only load
what you need.
Anyone else got a
good question?
MALE SPEAKER: Can I ask one?
CHRIS BANES: Please.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Go for it.
Was that the question?
NICK BUTCHER: Is he frozen?
CHRIS BANES: He might
have done.
He's actually stopped moving.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: He's
holding very still.
Have we frozen?
CHRIS BANES: No, Yossi's
[INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Sorry
about that.
CHRIS BANES: Oh, Hangout.
MALE SPEAKER: So I was trying to
use number picker from both
Android 4 and Android 2, just
trying to have an application
working in both, and it's
a bit of a hassle.
And I ended up having to copy
the entire number picker from
2 to my application and
use that one because
if you try to use--
there are some methods that are
change of signatures for
Android, I think API level
11 or something.
Is there any strategy
that you would
recommend for such things?
CHRIS BANES: Not really.
I've been working on this kind
of stuff recently quite a lot,
compatibility.
And the best way is to just
drag the source into your
source tray, because you have
then control over it, and
there's no nice way
of doing it.
Because the trouble with that
kind of stuff as well, you
have to drag in all
the styles.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, and it
becomes a big problem.
But there's no easy, nice way of
doing it unless you find a
library that already
has it for you.
NICK BUTCHER: I was going to
say, I assume somebody has
probably already done
this array.
CHRIS BANES: But yeah, there's
no easy way unless you can
find a library which has
already done the work.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, but probably
the work would be the
same [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Exactly.
So you're looking to use the
new version of the number
picker in an old wrap,
in a backwards
backhaul way, you're saying?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
If you run your application in
Eclipse, everything is fine.
And you try to run it in an
Android 2 device, it will
crash because it can't
find the class.
And the class is there, but the
signature is different so
the fast loader doesn't
recognize it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I used the
number pickers in the Ultimate
Stopwatch, and I just API check
it and then use the
right ones for 2.3 and the new
ones for Ice Cream Sandwich.
So if you look at the Ultimate
Stopwatch's source code--
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, will do.
RICHARD HYNDMAN:
Ulimatestopwatch
.googlecode.com, it's open
source there and you can see
the way I did it.
I just used the two separate
chunks of code to make the two
different number pickers work.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, that's
more or less what I did.
An if.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah,
that's what I did.
I just did an If check on it.
You'll find that, for Android
2 upwards, you have code for
newer versions.
As long as you don't execute it
in the older versions, you
can have it just API
catered in there.
NICK BUTCHER: Or you could have
two different concrete
implementations and just
instantiate the right one
depending on runtime
[INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, but at a
certain point, you have to
have that If.
Which one are you
going to use?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Well, just target Ice Cream
Sandwich and upwards.
STEPHAN LINZNER: OK, thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: Or [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN:
Or [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: All righty.
CHRIS BANES: All right.
We've got two--
that depends how long we--
I was going to say
two minutes left.
STEPHAN LINZNER: One
more question.
We have this one--
NICK BUTCHER: Oh yeah,
two minutes left.
And Richard [INAUDIBLE] again.
CHRIS BANES: So CM has
asked, how can we
become a Top Developer?
Our app has over 700,000
downloads and a rating of 4.4.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Awesome.
Well, congratulations.
That's pretty damn good stats.
Does he say what the
application is?
CHRIS BANES: No, he doesn't.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We get
a lot of people
asking about Top Developer.
We haven't issued-- or the
Player [INAUDIBLE] team
haven't issued any Top
Developer badges in--
it must be over a year now
because we were talking about
it at I/O last year.
The whole program's
still on hold.
I guess they're trying to figure
out what to do with it.
I don't have too many details on
it, but there haven't been
any new Top Developers issued
in a long time.
NICK BUTCHER: But even before
that, the kind of guidelines
where you had to have a string
of very good applications,
normally multiple, unless you're
a service which is only
ever going to have
one application.
So normally one app
isn't sufficient.
You normally have to have
a string of apps.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, the
program became a bit
fragmented.
They definitely used it for
things like banks as well,
even if the app wasn't high
quality, they used it to put
the tick next to things like a
bank so you'd think it was the
trusted application
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Verified
and [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Verified.
So we should have split it into
two programs, a verified
[INAUDIBLE] and a trusted
developer.
So it's just kind of--
yeah.
Sorry about that.
NICK BUTCHER: A lot of these
programs, we're waiting on the
new Google Play Store to launch,
so now that that's
started rolling out, then I
think we're going to hopefully
be able to do more interesting
schemes like this.
So hopefully, watch this space
for that kind of program.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: The new Play
Store is a lot more flexible
for that sort of thing.
Maybe that's what they're
waiting for.
OK, well in the last minute, I
will reiterate one more time
that this is the last Android
Developer Office Hours.
Bye bye.
We did the first Android
Developer Office Hours in
January 2012, January
11, 2012.
We've been going
for 15 months.
NICK BUTCHER: I think Yossi's
been here more than me.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yossi's
probably done
more than me, yeah.
In the 15 months, we've only
missed a handful of weeks.
And oh, Giuseppe's great.
It's been a good run.
In fact, the first three months
until March were just
Hangouts with up to 10 people,
because Hangouts didn't even
exist in January last year.
They came in in March last year,
and that's when we went
online and started doing YouTube
live and Hangouts on
air and all that stuff.
I remember Sparky having to find
his way around, because
Hangouts [INAUDIBLE]
in Germany.
He had to fly over every week to
join the Hangout, or drive
out of Germany to join
the Hangout.
That's what happened, yeah.
So we will be taking a break
now until after Google I/O,
and after Google I/O, our new
studio here will be ready and
we will come back with a
vengeance, apparently, and
blow you away with
a brand new show.
So thank you all.
NICK BUTCHER: But you guys
should all just get together
every Wednesday at
2:00 PM, right?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Oh
yeah, totally.
If you have a Hangout,
I'll join anyway.
That's fine.
We'll just have a chat.
NICK BUTCHER: I'll just be
furiously writing slides at
the same time.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Fireside chat.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah,
fireside chat.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI:
I lost two times.
One time, because I will miss
you team after the Google I/O,
and second time because I was
not able to get the ticket to
come there.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Aw, Giuseppe.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Made
look, Richard.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I know,
I'm ashamed.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm sorry.
Many people [INAUDIBLE].
But are you going to go to
an I/O Extended event?
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Yes,
in my region.
Yes, in Italy.
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Perfect.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: My company
will be the official sponsors
of the extended Google I/O, and
also, we will be there to
support all the developer.
NICK BUTCHER: Wonderful.
Sounds great.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: So thanks to
everyone who joined us in the
Office Hours over the last 15
months and supported it, and
we've answered quite
a lot of questions.
I wish we'd kept a
tally of how many
questions we'd answered.
And that's us for today.
So thank you all very much.
We'll see you all around.
We know you all anyway,
and we're on Google+.
MALE SPEAKER: Enjoy.
Bye bye.
NICK BUTCHER: You're taking
a break from us.
We'll see you soon.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]